and regards to el chapo el chapo is a
1957 guy you're 1973 when you started so
he was 16 so you've probably never done
anything with el chapo or any nothing
not at all because he came later on
got it and so
outside of that with pablo and ochoa
you you've been very complimentary about
pablo but at the same time you said when
i found that amount of people he killed
i you know i was disappointed by that
what's your relationship in how you
summon how he treated you to what he did
later on how do you view pablo is it
like a complicated way you view him
no i just think that he just turned bad
did he just probably the stress or
whatever it was and you people start
shooting and killing each other people
it's like in war look what's happening
now with putin and you wouldn't think
that about him
a couple of months ago seeing him but he
turned and killing tens of thousands of
people
do you think
good men
are
capable
of i guess the question will be the
following do you think more
of good men are capable doing evil
things or evil men are more capable of
being good
wow
i don't know i think all of us all of us
could do bad things if enough if we had
the right provocation
and i think all of us want to do good if
we're just living and be around us and
people are nice to us and you say hello
and good morning and we i love everybody
where somebody's killing my family
i turned into something different
yeah i agree i want him out of
conversation with my dad and i told my
dad i said dad
do you think you're capable of killing
someone he says never i said that stop
this is never i'm telling you i could
never do it you meet my dad my dad you
know
you know what it is yeah he's i'm not
capable of doing something to anybody i
said that stop it i said take one your
grandkid somebody does something to him
right in front of you
if you have a choice between killing
them or what would you do he says
well maybe i'm capable of doing
something
life changes a little bit right when you
get to that but uh have you seen evil
evil men become good
no
no no
have you met many evil men throughout
your lifetime yes in prison there's
something that should be executed
seriously absolutely tell me more
well we had a fellow in there named
stick'm steve
and stickham steve was a guy about my
size but i i think he'd kill thirty came
in to do three three years and he killed
13 people while he was in there
13 people in there in prison over the
years he'd go in a year or two in
solitary and he'd get out and he killed
somebody else maybe he wouldn't get
convicted of it he killed somebody else
and then he killed somebody else so
prisoners yeah
and for what reason whatever just didn't
bother him so you come in we had a
little tv room there long park is
maximum security prison where somebody
was killed every month when i was there
murder every every 30 days somebody was
killed what city is this long park
california here okay
they got cameras in there knocked it
down to three or four years but when i
was there it was bad
so steve would come in
turn the television camera at three
o'clock we had
headphones to plug in in a
little tv room glassed in you all know i
watched bananas every day at three
o'clock and the guys would just lay the
headsets down and go like i wasn't
scared of steve i just didn't want to
kill him i didn't want to trouble with
him so i just put my head sitting down
and watched bananas on one of the other
well i was down on
cell 17 and my friend phil was 18 and i
was a little slow getting my cup of
coffee my coffee to go down to the end
to the with the hot water heater wasn't
really 15 or 20 men down there getting
it
and
my friend phil's coming down and he says
and i'm going he says you don't want to
go down there
what's going on phil he said you don't
want to see
[ __ ] i do want to see and i go down
there there's nobody there it's placed
bigger than this room
and i look and i get my hot water in my
instant coffee and i look across and
there's steve with his shirt off
but the rail
and he turns around and comes to me and
it looks like a car spring has been
stuck through him all the way through
his chest and it's out his back
oh boy and he come right up to me and
like a little boy says
can can you help me
can you can you help me
i said no steve i don't buddy i don't
believe i can help you and he said can
can anybody help me
and he went back over to the rail and he
leaned over and the blood started coming
out of his mouth and dropped down by the
guard station and course the guard hit
the button and here all the guards come
50 of them and they're going up them
stairs shaking it like boom boom boom
boom
and his boss he painted painted the
house and his boss was a tubby fella
about 30 years old and they had had an
argument the day before and he almost
put steve in the jokey
and he ran right up to steve and he was
like me he didn't see it to start with
him when he saw it he dropped dead of a
heart attack right in front of steve's
feet
get out of here i'm around the corner
kind of having a look and all those
people and then steve fell down on him
just the two of them did right there
together
and they locked us up for two weeks and
i mean they treated us bad they come to
everything out of the cell
with guns in my face they say something
reef say something who's they who was
what that guard his name was clark
but what did what did steve do at that
point where he just he just fell did he
just no but who did he kill at that
point he didn't kill anybody somebody
had come into his cell while he's still
laying on the mattress and put that up
with that he put that metal through him
it went out into his mattress threw it
through him and he didn't kill him right
then he lived another five minutes so
his was the first cell there on that
side and so he just walked out and
how many different prisons have you been
in but wait i want to stay on the story
here so this guy so did you guys finally
find out who killed the guy or no nobody
wanted to know who killed him how many
people wanted to sell in the prison with
you guys at that time 1400. oh so you're
not going to find that and about 200 in
my unit and i was a maximum unit and
there were some bad boys in there
but you're saying steve had it coming
absolutely 13 people you're kidding me
every time he goes down there so so
eventually people somebody was going to
take this guy out
but somebody should have done it a long
time ago somebody did a long time ago
the government should have done it i
mean why are we going to
you believe in death penalty 100 when i
went in i didn't but after living with
some of those
people that
black bob cut a man
open and ate his heart and put him under
my bed knee 17 before i got there what
yeah so i mean you live with somebody
cut a guy up and ate his heart he cut
his heart up he killed him he couldn't
what jail did you go to like this this
is this is in california
penitentiary
right there 1400 men 12 dying a year
average that's why i asked the question
about how many different jails you've
been to and what was the worst
you're trying to compare like how bad
yeah compared to this yeah yeah you've
been to mexican jail you've been to jail
in california i assume you've been to
jail you've been in jail in australia 26
of them how many different jails and
what's the worst situation to be in in
mexico okay by far no no doubt about it
this is cleaned up somewhat now
uh
than what it was there's where i was 11
years
or maybe not much you look at it right
now what do you think when you see this
picture does it do anything to you i
just think what a terrible situation the
united states has all those men in there
half of them don't belong there
half of them don't don't do no don't
belong there yet but so go back to death
penalty and then i want to ask you the
question on the half and half so death
benefit you're fully forward you went in
not being forward yeah you're left
saying no we we need that penalty
there's some people in there that you
know like black bob i mean maybe just
you just kill you if you fool with him
and you're just like i don't know he
played and he had shot heroin up and and
uh he had plenty of sense i played chess
almost every day and he'd be nodding off
and i said come on bob move and he'd
move and make it okay and beat me so he
ain't no shortage but
to do something like that and he's in
there for murder
did any of that so did you go in
uh as a simple guy did you come out with
some bad ugly
uh um maybe not habits but like your
view of the world and your intentions
changed where
you could do more harm than you went in
or you went in you came out the same
human being
i think i came up pretty much the same
thing but i i i know what i mean i got
tougher as the years went by in there
yes you see it these teeth are not my
own
i left them in a man's neck
what happened there he was winning
okay i got you
he had his hair and i pulled it over and
gave him a good bite and that was the
end of that did you do that right after
seeing a tyson fight or was that like
inspiration came from i should give him
i should give him some lessons
after the year you went up to the head
do you think it's
there must be some i know you said i'm a
simple man you know i'm just here yeah
there must be
deep below maybe not on the surface
maybe something you don't even like
talking about a deep sense of
cunningness
a an acute sense of not at all there's
got to be something in there you're
hanging out with pablo escobar with the
choa you're hanging out with these
literal murderers but yeah you're just
they weren't then they were just like us
sitting here they absolutely you can't
look at the man too but even in prison
though roger what are some of those
people that guys something bob you said
what did you call him black black bob
black bob do you think he was always
evil yes
so you think some people are well known
listen no little babies born evil
no i get that but do you think like he's
been bad for a long time i don't know
what happened to him to make him that
way but from you being around them i'm
just curious analyzing some of these
guys how much of that is parenting how
much of that is their own dna
there's a bunch of their own dna because
it follows i see it in families
grandfather father son comes right on in
there
push yourself down that's what you're
going to hash it down look at animals
you've got you've got [ __ ] hook and
gore you get rid of them
in person you heard uh
gets gets a better disposition it's
crazy to know that the perspective here
to believe in death penalty after seeing
what many of these guys did so and did
you ever see
well you said no you didn't see
you said half the people in america
shouldn't be in jail the ones that are
in jail shouldn't be in jail the other
half deserve to be in there how do they
end up in there how broken is the system
that we have
it's horribly broken why and how
okay a lot of the people in prison not
in those prisons but in the lesser
prisons making up the population and
camps and farms and this
a de ager to go under the bridge with
his mustache and his uh
tattoos all over him and he'll shoot
harom with these guys or he'll snort a
little bit of whatever
and
he'll get one of themselves two or three
grams of methamphetamine to the other
one and now he's got two busts
and he takes them to jail
and boy now i've got two so he does that
every month or two so whenever it's come
for who's going to make sergeant guess
who makes sergeant the one that's got
all these little arrests
or maybe someone a little bit bigger but
i'm just just making
so now then he goes to a young
prosecutor and the prosecutor comes to
say but we're going to give you 10 years
if you don't plead guilty buddy
and you've got a public defender
i'm going to make sure you do 10 years
if you'll take five
you can do it now the prosecutor says
okay
and it's full of them okay you're gonna
have to do four on the five
and
so he's had two grams of methamphetamine
and i'm i'm in waiting on a parole
hearing in oklahoma city
which i'm not ever which i never got
and uh so i meet a fella from
santa barbara and where are you going he
said i'm going to atlanta i got caught
with two two grams of methamphetamine
and i'm going to atlanta for
for psychiatric evaluation
and then i meet a nice young fella from
albany georgia where are you going he
said i'm going to los angeles i got
caught with two grams of methamphetamine
i'm going for psychiatric evaluation i
imagine they cost the government thirty
thousand fifty thousand dollars to take
them across country and leave them a
month in oklahoma city at the big big
exchange there 17 planes i believe i
don't know for sure which [ __ ] uh
fed air
con air don't ask who owns it
hey some and now the people of the
government and the people of the united
states don't want to pay that
it's these people they're lining their
own pockets with it in their own
retirements and it's it's wrong it's
really wrong
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]